last halloween after you won the bet i
went back to my office to do everyone's
paperwork but i did no paperwork i
started to plot my revenge i began by
creating a word cloud but how could you
possibly have known i was going to try
and steal your watch i knew you were
trying to take something important to me
during the year i drew your attention
to my watch
you're eight minutes late
you're 14 minutes late you're three
minutes early
in chicago
[Music]
you annoyed me into stealing it exactly
now you had a target but you needed a
plan fortunately it walked through the
door handcuffed to diaz
scumbag pickpocket is dan mccreary you
can take anything off of anyone anything
anyone the look on your face priceless i
put mccreary into my employee
immediately fast forward to this morning
you commenced your plan mccreary stole
my watch and then replaced it with a
replica and while you celebrated
mccreary put my watch back in my pocket
the watch never left my person
[Music]
i can see that you're enjoying this not
nearly as much as i enjoyed phase two
while you met with mccreary santiago
placed a fire hydrant in front of your
car which she then towed away next i had
to take charles out of the equation he
had a badge and a gun and he would do
anything to help you enter a parade of
drunks that separated the two of you
long enough for terry to kidnap charles
then two bears spilled their drinks on
you and stole your wallet those beers
scully
and hitchcock i can't put my head off
if terry kidnapped charles how did
charles tell me to get on the party bus
eight months ago at a morning briefing i
told the squad that a group of thieves
was targeting party buses so i could
record charles saying
jake party bus
get on board
i knew boyle would never knowingly
betray me with your jacket and shoes
gone you didn't look like a cop but you
still had your badge that is until you
entered
the party bus
rosa's feline dancing distracted you as
a mysterious party or stole your badge
on
halloween it was you in the mask you sly
son of a [ __ ]
well done but i do have to ask those
guys at the impound did they really
smash my car no in fact i had them wash
it
good one captain you can't wash a car so
how'd you convince the whole squad to
betray me what'd you offer them i asked
them if they wanted to embarrass you and
they instantly said yes
i'm not gonna lie that turns me on a
little bit
so
in addition to the five weeks of free
overtime
i believe i mowed one more thing yes
here we go one target
[Music]
[Applause]
so how'd you pull it off well it all
started when i went to tell jake how
badly hurt my feelings and he yelled at
my breasts oh boy i am not going to come
off well in this story nope remember
when you set off the witch
he made captain holt flinch which was
weird since his door was closed but not
weird since he actually heard it over a
bug he planted at your desk it was in an
old muffin that you never threw in the
trash that's why people throw away
garbage how are we together
anyway i tapped into the bug's frequency
so i had ears on jake i needed to know
what holt was up to that's where
hitchcock came in
i masterminded the entire plan you did
one small thing and i had to explain it
to you like 45 times he left a tiny
crack in the blind so i could read the
captain's lips sharon and your kids will
distract jake they'll be here at 9 30
sharp my waffle xylophone on the cheese
man what my lip reading is not flawless
now that i knew your plan it was simple
to disrupt while scully gracefully moved
the witch i got into character holt
triggered the witch which brought jake
into the room and i threw the crown in
the trash can exactly as i planned
then i sent you all here placed an out
of order sign on the perfectly
functional elevator made you all walk up
31 flights of stairs and vomit twice
actually it was four times if you count
all the stairwell stuff you thought i
was just holds lackey and you thought i
was just jake's girlfriend well i'm my
own person capable of making my own
decisions and i decided to humiliate you
both well you did and
it was awesome
one last question where's the crown oh
it's at shaw's bar the official site of
my coronation
all hail the crown of destiny
and all hail she who wears it amy
santiago
the
queen queen
of the nine-nine
i believe there's something else you
both need to say gladly
amy santiago is an amazing detective
slash genius
drinks are on us nope
drinks on me yeah
you fell for my trap like a greedy
little rat easy yes it was easy and the
next phase of my plan
a quote-unquote skating accident but you
knocked out your two front teeth false
teeth
fake blood
i lost my real teeth at den sutton's
birthday party in fourth grade oh you
made sure i didn't remember that it was
minute five of seven minutes in heaven
with todd cohen when he bumped the wall
and the bowling ball fell on my face
maybe i just wasn't at that party once
i'd faked the skating mishap i swapped
out a dummy plaque for the real one then
i left to go to the dentist can you
convince your dentist to help you carry
out the rest of the heist no of course
not go ahead i came back wearing the
perfect disguise to make sure i was
never noticed by anyone something so
drab and uninspiring feels like it's
gonna be a dig on me i wore amy's
clothes there it is this is your doing
you and your male prostitute bill is not
a male prostitute i don't think that
suit is not drab it has a fun salmon
lining no amy it made me invisible and
now that i had that power every time one
of you stole a plaque i replaced it with
a fake and no one had any idea until the
lights went out revealing a secret
message heists are dumb then we raced in
here to blame terry and you trapped us
but how did you know he was gonna say
heists are dumb terry says that about
everything everyone should wear
suspenders belts are dumb people should
swim forward the backstroke is dumb 30
grams of fat hummus is dumb and now here
you all are locked up behind the glass
like a bunch of loser fish this is
incredible how'd you do it rosa well
back on halloween i knew jake would make
the first move
and i had to be ready you were hiding in
the fog it wasn't hult to put that chair
in my pathway no i did i wanted to be
the one who was responsible for our
victory what we already lost there's no
point in trying to maintain team around
now dick anyway i knew cheddar would be
making an appearance oh everyone loves
to see cheddar he's here a lot i never
bring an arlo who exactly i spent every
morning for the last year giving cheddar
a taste for him oh so that's why he got
so thick and ended up on chunky pups i
submitted his photo and once you put
cheddar on a diet all i had to do was
mark the gems a little that sweet ham
taste why did you want cheddar to
swallow the gems because i needed to
delay things the second part of my plan
took place on valentine's day which went
perfectly i wouldn't say perfectly
scully swallowed the gems so i tricked
him into it wasn't hard pretty much used
the same cheddar hand playbook table ham
seven days in a row so now i have to
think twice before i eat food i find
lying around thanks a lot i mark the
gems with ham again and everything
pushed to easter when i could finally
get rid of scully as my partner doctor
i'm willing to pay you to tell norm
skully not to participate participate no
no norm scully should not be
participating in any activities he could
die i'll go call him right now now i
finally had a teammate whose hand i
could cut off just needed a little help
from terry boy that thing's pretty heavy
huh
did you bring the tools
well you were retired you were loving
your smoothies yeah but after a while i
felt left out and if i'm being honest
smoothies weren't even that good i
wonder why that was maybe it's because i
ham your smoothie am i the only one who
didn't get fed ham this year wait how
did you know about jake's bunny plan you
weren't the only one listening in all
this therapy of course the bunny should
have glasses i just can't believe i
didn't come up with it myself oh you
know what betty rubble also gives me a
bump you guys were listening in on my
therapy that feels like a real violation
hey jake jake this is rosa's moment yeah
man go tell to your fake therapist she's
fake anyway then i grabbed the gems
jumped off the roof wrote my name in
flames wait why did you keep delaying
the heist couldn't you have just wanted
halloween oh i did
these are the real halloween gems i
switched them out before cheddar found
them i also won on valentine's day what
is happening switched those gems out
before i gave him a skully and then
i won today so while you nerds are
always arguing about who the only
two-time champion is me i just became
the first three-time champion
hello jacob ah
ames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and i both
know the belt never left the precinct i
don't know that nobody knows that i kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key and
then it hit me they didn't they swapped
the safe one of the handmaids i'm
assuming fake charles took my safe and
then of amy deposited a look-alike
who did you give fake charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of financial freedom
i invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake charles broke into
the safe removed the tracker and led
terry in the whole squad on a wild goose
chase my only question is which box is
the belt in well good luck figuring it
out because the clock is tick tick
tocking it's that one no the dust
pattern on top doesn't match its
neighbors
you see jake i'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you're just plain
boring again weird take on a very loving
relationship and it's midnight so i
guess i'm an amazing human slash genius
yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that they're built why
oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
you